and now everyone on the couch when
you've been toured shows the offers
governor's you've all taken your parents
which is I mean that seems you know
sample poor you all dude everything
right I just me that's not Ryan your mom
she I mean I'm sure she likes meeting
some buddies but isn't the gift room is
really her thing she enjoys I don't want
to help my mom like this I will tell her
funny story about that picture though
which is that my mom was convinced that
year by her friend that beehives were
going to be all the rage if he didn't
have a beehive you'd feel embarrassed
and it's turned out to be the opposite
it was a natural hair vibe but and my
mom sat in front of Rachel wide and her
hair was so high that Rachel had to keep
my mom from making an inner chair and I
didn't know what to do because I was you
know I'd wanted to have a nice night so
I I didn't know Meryl Streep but she was
sitting next to me and I said in a
commercial break would you would you
mind just telling my mom you like her
hair and she was like I got this and
then the commercial when she was you
know I wish I was going to do a beehive
and I wish I like carotene oh that story
your mom my mom yeah
yeah good Emily your mother did she
pretend to not know the famous people or
does she just get a bit overexcited and
forget early on she well I mean in that
when the first time I went to the Golden
Globes just says bring that back around
that was this year and we were sitting
next to now if you know not a fun to
talk about but we were talking sitting
next Angelina Jolie and Brad Pitt and
she was just asking multiple questions
like if they had kids maybe you know
what's it like I think I had no idea the
whole time you won your second Oscar
with apartment oh yes yes it was a vibe
right yeah let me put it this way it was
my last one but it was 1995 and that was
a very special year for the man sitting
beside you Peter Capaldi because that
was the year you were in austerity I won
an Oscar yes for little a short film I
didn't even know that they gave Oscars
for short films but I'd made this little
short film because I was interested in
filmmaking and the next thing I knew I
was being telephoned and being told that
you were nominated for an Oscar we
didn't even have any money we didn't
know how to get over there all right but
so we managed to cobble together of
Mali's get over there and we find
ourselves at the Oscars whether yourself
and bands that lots of other film stars
and they call my name and I got up on
the stage now look down and it was a
huge auditorium like this and it just
looked to me that it was full of um you
know an Arnold Schwarzenegger look-alike
look like a Tom Hanks look like except
it was the real thing
and if it's organic I don't know how it
was for you but for me
what I do is my last warrior that night
must have sent you into a tailspin do
you go crazy that that actual night did
you go nuts actually I remember I
remember very clearly going back with my
girlfriend at the time and we went to
her house and she went to sleep and and
hi
I had a ponytail backpack but but i but
I couldn't sleep I was just kind of
still buzzing it and I was sitting there
and I remember very clearly looking at
that award and and and thinking very
very clearly am I allowed to say a
four-letter word on this ribbon I
literally looked at it I was alone with
it and I said to myself thank God I
didn't [ __ ] anybody over for this huh
and I suddenly had this kind of swing
wash over me where I thought imagine
chasing that and not getting it and
getting it finally in your 80s or your
90s with all of life behind you and
realizing what an unbelievable waste of
your you know what I mean because it
can't it's got to be you know what I
mean it's not it's a complicated update
right it can't fill you up it will never
if that's a hole that you have that
won't fill it right and and I felt so
like blessed to have that awareness at
someone it said and learning about it
learn it and because I wouldn't have
known it unless I knew it you know
anyway like imagine figuring out of a TV
how and I literally like my heart broke
for a second I it's like I imagined
another one of me you know an old man
kind of going like oh my god where did
my life go what if what have I done and
then it's over yeah
looking back you've got a rejoicing you
have that amazing success so early on or
there's a bit of you kind of not regret
it but sort of I don't know think was a
bit of a curse I I mean I don't think it
was a curse but I couldn't really
appreciate it I mean it was very
hallucinatory it was like I don't know
if you've ever been a traffic accident
but there's that moment where you go my
god
I'm going to crash into this wall over
here you know everything so slows down
and you're spinning around that was how
it kind of felt they said our names and
looked at man and was like should we get
up and we get up and there's you know
people are clapping there you know and
there was a Jack Lemmon and Walter
Matthau presented it to us and you know
Billy Crystal was hosting and he's been
ratting been bad and you know I was 24
years old I mean I barely knew anything
at all and and it was you know I mean I
think it was in some ways trouble to get
that much attention that young and I
really didn't have any perspective on it
at all it was a wonderful honor but it
was a you know I certainly appreciated
later on much more what it meant
you're really generous with the Oscar on
you well one Drive you know everyone the
thing is first of all it's very heavy I
just need to say that it weighs about
six or seven pounds it's really
surprisingly heavy so and everyone wants
to have a hold of course and wants to
stand up and overcome I'd like to thank
my primary school teachers my mum and
dad and so the best place really for
Oscar is actually the loo because then
when everyone goes in for a wee RUP ooh
they can really take their time in front
of the mirror with Oscar always tell
because they flushed and there's another
five minutes
you're playing with us come on how is
Oscar they go oh my god I mean I know
that have you been a good a sec if you
go off you have your day back I think so
what is the theme of this show if you
don't have
[Music]